so the idea behind the 11 million dream
story thon is that immigrants already
mediamakers immigrants allies
organizations and activists who work in
support of immigrant communities in the
United States we already have the
stories of our lives of our experiences
in the United States as immigrants we
are all already media makers so the idea
behind the 11 million dream story thon
is for us to gather together to share
those stories to learn media and tech
tools so that these stories can be
amplified there's no one piece of
legislation that's gonna adequately
represent all of the stories that's
gonna adequately represent the diversity
of the immigrant stories of the 11 plus
million immigrants in the United States
so we hope that by guy other roofing
together October 5th and six in Los
Angeles and Boston and wherever you are
that by learning together by sharing
these stories together we can uplift
these voices and more importantly Center
lived immigrant experiences stories
learning to tell stories learning how to
share stories that in itself is an
activist school that's gonna counter a
lot of the narrative that we hear coming
from the mainstream media and even
coming from organizations
this isn't about talking points this
isn't about this is not about hitting
specific messages this is about real
lives and we want everyone's real life
to be seen as valuable and important and
adequately represented as we talked
about what needs to happen in terms of
legislation in terms of Human Rights so
that all immigrants in the United States
really get what they need and what they
deserve